juste pour vous il y a une tierce
personne qui maltraitait le chien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de Liège se sont aussi parfois traduites
par des débordements provoquant la
colère de certains internautes
alors donc oui quelques incidents mais
la fierté la fierté et la joie du peuple
marocain et c'est pas parce qu'on
brandit un drapeau marocain qu'on aime
pas la France les gens confondent c'est
la fierté de ses origines c'est parce
que on est content donc moi je trouve
que les Marocains ont été exemplaires je
leur dis bravo qui continuent à fêter ça
parce que quand j'entends parler
débordements franchement les vidéos
c'est c'est les premières sa première
fois que je les vois j'imagine qu'il y
en a eu et on va pas les on va pas dire
non c'est triste mais le plus important
c'est les images qu'on voit c'est que la
plupart des personnes ils sont heureux
heureuse voilà il y a par exemple Bruno
Retailleau qui a dit pourquoi les scènes
de liesse au Maroc ne donnent pas lieu à
des dégradations comme en France
simplement parce que nous acceptons
depuis des années d'être des paillassons
d'accueil des gens qui s'essuient les
pieds sur notre pays en toute impunité
moi ce qui me gêne c'est cette
récupération politique et de voir après
tous les les sur les réseaux des des
phrases qui étaient racistes etc et qui
se sont emparés du truc pour pouvoir
déverser leurs rênes ça c'est des
astreux moi je vois pas pourquoi je
devrais me résoudre aujourd'hui en
France il y a des débordements je vois
pas pourquoi on caillasse les filles je
vois pas pourquoi on met le feu à des à
du mobilier urbain voilà je me réjouis
c'est quoi alors en fait c'est quoi le
jeu ça s'est passé au Pays-Bas ça s'est
passé en Belgique ça se passe en France
donc pourquoi à votre avis pourquoi
alors il y a une signification politique
à ça il a récupéré politique qui a été
beaucoup repris qui était partagé ça
Amiens ou le drapeau marocain était
brandi sur la façade de l'Hôtel de Ville
regardez
[Musique]
l'histoire avec une signification
politique ça par exemple de faire ça à
votre avis franchement je vois même pas
le rapport de voilà c'est une
provocation de comme je vous ai dit des
1 2% ou les médias ils aiment aller sur
eux et après ça fait ce qu'on fait des
gens disent que ça c'est hyper bien
passé sur les gens après bien sûr donc
les médias ils se focalisent sur eux et
après ça fait une image de ses enfants
c'était les spectateurs s'il vous plaît
merci oui oui ou pas
à 80% les gens
Julien
tu nous avais alerté de ta situation
et aujourd'hui tu as dû fermer ta
boulangerie depuis de nombreuses
semaines tu sentais la catastrophe
arrivée comment tu payais d'électricité
pour ta boulangerie avant sa flambe
avant je payais 4500 euros annuellement
d'accord annuellement voilà là
maintenant je suis passé à 130014000 €
tous ces élus là qui font de la
propagande sur tous les médias la
semaine dernière on a vu Bruno Le Maire
sur un média je sais pas si il faut le
citer ou pas sur BFM qui a dit qu'il
laisserait crever personne aucune
entreprise aucun commerçant je veux dire
moi j'ai envie de rencontrer ce ministre
et lui dire venez avec moi j'ai le
liquidateur je suis en liquidation
judiciaire depuis une semaine pourquoi
avoir des besoins d'aide je veux dire
nous on veut juste bosser décemment je
veux dire la vie d'un boulanger vous
savez ce que c'est Cyril c'est 80 heures
semaine on a pas de Noël pas de jours
férié pas de dimanche je veux dire 80
heures semaine tu sais qu'il fait 80
heures semaine et qui sort pas de
salaire je reviens savoir qui est autour
de cette table se sort pas de salaire
avec 80 semaines j'ai l'impression
d'abandonner tous mes clients je veux
dire vous serez venus dimanche mais vous
aurez vu le scandale dimanche là il y a
3 jours je suis révolté j'ai envie de
tout brûler je suis en colère je suis
c'est voilà vous avez fermé
définitivement ah oui je suis en
liquidation judiciaire mais j'ai le
droit à 0 aide je tiens à le dire 00
parce que je rentre pas dans les
critères parce qu'ils prennent les
factures d'électricité de 2021
l'histoire des compteurs des
kilowatt-heure il y a il y a un nombre
incalculable de critères qu'on nous a
sorti et forcément les boulangers nous
on n'est pas dedans je suis désolé là
c'est impossible de repartir ah non mais
moi je veux même plus Cyril hein je suis
dégoûté du système moi je veux même plus
mettre un pied dans une boulangerie moi
c'est fini quoi c'est je me reconvertir
avant un boulot gagner ma vie
convenablement et plus d'emmerde plus
rien je fais des ulcères je fais des
migraines des blocages de dos je veux
dire j'ai 32 ans j'ai jamais fait ça de
ma vie non non ça se passait bien
on peut même pas dire que je faisais je
vais dire ma comptable j'aurais préféré
faire de la merde qu'il y a personne qui
venait chez moi et au moins ça aurait
été plus simple là je suis en
progression tous les mois tous les ans
même en clientèle il y a rien qui va pas
il y a juste ces [ __ ] de charges de
merde c'est tout c'est incroyable
[Musique]
il faut être quel genre de merde pour
tabasser un chiot qui peut pas se
défendre vous l'avez acheté un éleveur
sérieux le chien priori avait pas de
souci
j'avais acheté un
staff en fait il avait pas de permis
l'éleveur qui nous l'a vendu vont ce
sont des très bons éleveurs il y a rien
à dire là-dessus mais en fait ils nous
ont expliqué que si on disait que
c'était un staff on pourrait nous
retirer la garde du chien donc en fait
ils nous ont proposé de voir un
vétérinaire pour changer la race et vu
que c'était illégal on n'a pas voulu le
faire tout simplement quel est votre
version d'effet pourquoi le chien s'est
retrouvé dans cet état alors nous
comptons totalement l'effet et vu que
l'affaire est toujours en cours au
niveau judiciaire nous pouvons pas plus
nous exprimer là-dessus et la seule
chose dont nous avons pu être coupable
c'est de ne pas avoir vu que notre
chaîne n'était pas bien en fait
le vétérinaire lui qui a examiné le
chien raconte qu'il a déterminé qu'il y
avait des fractures antérieures que tous
les toutes les souffrances du chien ne
dataient pas de cette journée mais qui
avait eu des actions violentes contre le
chien avant comment vous les expliquez
nous ce qu'on peut simplement dire sans
rentrer dans les détails c'est que il y
a une personne tierce qui s'occupait de
l'animal et nous on sait pas du tout
rendu compte que le chien était fracturé
ou quoi c'est à dire et pour parler du
vétérinaire ça aussi moi je peux le dire
parce que du coup moi je suis déjà passé
du coup devant juge oui et ils ont vu le
la semaine dernière l'émission que vous
aviez faites
ce qui m'a surpris c'est que entre ce
que vous vous aviez sur le plateau ce
qui était dit sur les réseaux et ce que
il y a eu devant le juge c'est pas du
tout la même expertise de vétérinaire ça
veut dire l'expertise que vous avez eu
c'était juste du copier-coller de ce que
la tiktokeuse avait mis sur les réseaux
mais l'expertise que nous on a eu avec
notre avocat et que la justice et que la
justice a on sa possession c'est quand
même on voulait parler on voulait
prendre la parole on devait déjà venir
la semaine dernière mais on n'a pas pu
parce que comme on vous a dit c'était
impossible c'est ça ça dure en fait nous
les preuves qu'on voulait apporter à ce
moment-là Cyril on avait déjà on était
déjà en contact ça ça prouver justement
certains de nous dire sauf que si on
aurait fait ça c'était rentré totalement
en en travail avec la justice et là on
allait devant d'autres problèmes en fait
pour vous il y a une tierce personne qui
maltraitait le chien c'est ça non ça on
peut pas on peut pas
se prononcer mais il reste plus que vous
après par contre c'est ça qui emmerdant
oui mais après il y a après il y a une
enquête c'est ça qui emmerde
surtout pour vous hein
cette petite tokeuse massacre le chien
dans la nuit pour le lendemain vous
faire accuser parce qu'elle vous déteste
hein c'est même pire que ça c'est 7 que
ça fait trois ans que tous les ans elle
trouve un nouveau truc un nouveau groupe
et qu'elle essaie de faire des attaques
personnelles ou visées pour l'invitez
quand même dans cette soirée
vous êtes victime elle visiblement c'est
votre c'est votre bourreau mais on nous
a parlé donc est-ce qu'on colporte
d'autres fake news d'un autre chien que
vous auriez eu avant Texas
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
ce chien qu'est-ce qu'il est devenu
absolument en fait acheter un chien qui
en fait était assez jeune enfin nous on
pensait qu'il avait deux mois et en fait
c'était une petite chaîne qu'on a appelé
Quinny et qui malheureusement avait des
vers depuis
le vétérinaire dans ce cas-là
qu'on appelait parce qu'en fait le
vétérinaire quand il a vu tout ce qui
s'est passé de lui-même nous a appelé et
nous a dit c'est n'importe quoi ce qui
vous arrive il dit à moi s'il y a un
problème ou quoi que ce soit je peux
vous envoyer les documents lui a dit oui
s'il vous plaît envoyez-nous les
documents parce que là on a vraiment
besoin du coup il faut essayer d'aller
dormir le chien et il meurt quoi c'est
ça qui est chiant
je viendrai pas dormir chez vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il faut faire la totale
pour moi c'était pas de la maltraitance
enfin je pense que je connaissais ma
chaîne mieux que vous aussi elle est
spectateurs et je pense qu'elle aurait
aboyé elle aurait fait un signe comme
quoi elle était pas contente et enfin
moi je la portais souvent et il y avait
aucun souci là-dessus donc
tu méfiée
justement on a dit tout à l'heure
qu'elle avait déjà sa petite bosse mais
comme vous pouvez voir justement elle
était potes
qu'on a vu il y a quand même un fossé
enfin je veux dire elle marchait très
bien il y a toutes les personnes qui
étaient sur le clip je l'ai pas porté
pendant 4 heures les scènes elles ont
duré 10 minutes elle était par terre
elle pouvait se déplacer enfin je veux
dire elle marchait très bien
[Musique]
récemment j'ai été diagnostiquée
avec un trouble neurologique très rare
qui était environ une personne
sur un million et on sait maintenant que
c'est la cause d'espace musculaire dont
je souffle et je ne peux pas toujours
utiliser mes cordes vocales pour chanter
comme je le souhaiterais je crois que le
public est un cannibale qui dévore les
artistes et
Céline c'est les célébrer pendant 30 ans
pendant 30 ans elle a tout donné elle a
elle a donné son âme son corps ses
forces sa vie et puis tout d'un coup
elle a eu un grand coup de un grand coup
de Trafalgar elle a perdu René elle a
perdu sa mère les deux piliers de sa vie
et tout d'un coup les deux piliers
n'étaient plus là et elle s'est écroulée
et depuis le corps se révolte son corps
se révolte alors évidemment ça passe par
les nerfs ça passe par les nerfs ça
passe par les l'espace ça passe par les
crampes les gens tord les insomnies
l'AMA maigrissement l'anorexie tout ça
c'est les nerfs alors évidemment on peut
lui donner Cyril tous les noms médicaux
qu'on veut on peut trouver des
appellations elle nous en propose une
pourquoi pas
comment elle a dit le syndrome des
hommes raides ça c'est quand même un
drôle de nom ça touche une personne sur
un million et surtout il y a une
hypersensibilité au bruit alors pour une
chanteuse comme elle en concert c'est
absolument impossible ça se matérialise
par quoi je peux pas supporter à un
moment son organisme effectivement ne
peut plus supporter le bruit les
lumières elle ne peut plus être stable
c'est très dangereux et surtout c'est
une maladie méconnue qui ne se soigne
pas honnêtement on a très peur qu'elle
ne puisse jamais rechanter évidemment il
les assurances gigantesques derrière
tout ça qui refuse le mot annulation
parce qu'il faudrait tout payer donc
elle passe son temps à dire que ce sont
des reports depuis deux ans il faut
savoir que les places de Céline Dion ça
va jusqu'à 500 700 750 euros pour les
carrés or pour la rencontrer donc il y a
des gens qui ont fait des efforts
gigantesques depuis deux ans et qui ne
sont pas remboursés par les assurances
et qui attendent des reports qui
viennent sans cesse et là c'est un peu
le report de trop parce qu'elle avait
annoncé au mois de juillet que ça y est
elle a attaqué sa tournée en Europe
d'ailleurs vous m'avez dit dans
l'émission que vous vous le sentiez pas
du tout et maintenant elle reporte de
nouveau elle a quand même le don disons
avec son staff de la communication je ne
veux pas être dire des choses mais elle
a le don de la communication elle sait
reprendre au moment où on est bientôt à
Noël on est bientôt aux fêtes de Noël
donc
elle sait reprendre au bon moment des
des petits messages émouvants ou et ce
n'est pas une comédie j'ai pas dit ça
hein ce n'est pas une comédie mais elle
sait bien gérer tout ça alors vous nous
rassurer
merci Sophie merci d'être là Sophie vous
êtes la fille de la victime cette femme
de 78 ans violée par SDF dans sa chambre
d'hôpital il y a aussi un centre
d'accueil de SDF dans cet hôpital
avec une autre patiente
et un homme qui n'est ni un patient ni
du personnel va alors rentrer dans sa
chambre il est 9h30 ça se passe en matin
et
10h oui c'est ça aux alentours de 9h30 à
peu près et il entre dans la chambre ma
mère le voit entrée et au début elle a
un petit doute elle se dit il a pas il a
pas il est pas comme il ressent pas un
infirmier un personnel soignant et il
entre dans la chambre il y a entre les
entre le lit de ma mère qui est du côté
de la porte et le lit de sa voisine il y
a il y a un rideau et il passe de
l'autre côté du rideau et regarde il
revient vers ma mère et ma mère là sans
qu'il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas
elle lui dit mais monsieur vous êtes
trompé enfin vous voulez il faut aller
voir les infirmières les médecins la
salle des infirmières un peu plus loin
et lui fait chut il lui fait ce signe et
la Grèce une première fois à ma mère
sexuellement
il faut savoir que ma mère ne pouvait
pas du tout marcher elle avait des
escarres sur une sur un pied donc elle
avait des bandages au pied les deux
pieds bandés et donc il a il la viole
une première fois et ensuite elle elle
surtout on fait quelque chose il revient
vers elle il essaie de la de la violer
une seconde fois et là elle prend son
membre et elle le tort
c'est la seule chose qu'elle a trouvé à
faire et c'est une bonne idée d'ailleurs
l'agresseur donc a eu le temps de fuir
mais derrière il va récidiver dans le
même hôpital dans le même hôpital une
demi-heure après même pas
parce que l'hôpital dans l'hôpital il y
a
un EHPAD et il y a une dame
de 68 ans qui qui rentrait chez elle et
il lui a demandé une cigarette il l'a
croisé lui a demandé une cigarette c'est
bon elle lui a répondu qu'elle en avait
pas je sais pas ce qu'elle leur a
répondu et il a sauté sur elle il a
frappé il a alors là il a il s'est
acharné sur elle et la frappé et là
et la violée voilà il a été appréhendé
le
suspect absolument oui les placer il est
mis en examen et placé en détention
provisoire depuis le mois de septembre
[Musique]
en tout cas ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'effectivement des faits similaires ce
sont déroulées 30 minutes après dans un
EHPAD dans les lieux publics au vu et au
sud de chacun donc là tu as déjà été
déposé Cyril à l'encon de l'hôpital pour
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
une enquête est ouverte donc suite à
cette plante une enquête est ouverte et
cette enquête elle doit amener plusieurs
réponses c'est absolument pas les
soignants qui sont dirigés
aux personnes morales qui à mon avis
devra répondre effectivement en tout cas
il y a une responsabilité à rechercher
de ce côté-là c'est une infirmière qui
est intervenue voilà pour faire
l'agresseur c'est une soignante
aujourd'hui
la plainte elle est dirigée vous l'avez
compris à l'endroit de la gouvernance et
la part de la part de sécurité qui était
la porte de secours par où le violeur
est passé elle était défectueuse elle
était défectueuse et tout ce qu'ils ont
trouvé à faire c'est de mettre une une
barre comme ça en bois qui empêche aussi
de sortir en cas de en cas de danger
[Musique]
menace harcèlement et agression
Jeremstar alerte sur les dérives des
réseaux sociaux et sort du silence dans
TPMP vous avez toutes ces histoires en
2018 et en fait ça s'est jamais arrêté
ça s'est jamais arrêté parce que je suis
condamné en fait à perpétuité sur les
réseaux sociaux pour toutes ces
calomnies c'est vrai que cette histoire
du jeremstargate à l'époque a énormément
fait parler et puis les spectateurs ce
sont des choses qui sortent en fait même
des réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui et qui
se répercutent dans ta vie puisque
actuellement il y a plusieurs enquêtes
pour menaces de crime à mon encontre
matérialisé par écrit j'ai dû annuler
des dates de mon one man show parce
qu'il y avait des menaces d'attentat sur
ma tournée j'ai encore reçu ce truc il y
a trois jours avec des menaces de mort
je me fais retenir en otage dans Paris
par un djihadiste qui est persuadé que
je suis pédophile enfin c'est invivable
en fait c'est un vivable et la rumeur
tue et aujourd'hui
ouais je m'accroche parce qu'en fait
c'est c'est invivable tu as une élite et
net de menace que tu as reçu récemment
donc alors ça c'est après avoir reçu des
seringues ensanglantées dans ma boîte
aux lettres donc je donc voilà petit
[ __ ] on va te retrouver et te buter
ordures fais attention à toi partout ça
le maire de lâchera pas on a vu sur
internet tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
dit sur toi on sait que c'est vrai
cache-toi il vaut mieux pour ta sécurité
[ __ ] va crever et disparaître à tout
jamais en fait je pense qu'il faut que
je me suicide pour que
les choses avancent pas ça je pense à il
y a une influenceuse là qui s'est donné
la mort et que je suis toujours très ému
quand je parle d'elle elle s'appelait
mavache où c'était une maman elle était
accusée de choses horribles elle n'a pas
supporté en fait la lenteur judiciaire
elle s'est suicidée étrangement tous
s'est accéléré quand elle est morte donc
en fait oui c'est ce que je dis à chaque
fois dans les tribunaux il faut se
[ __ ] en l'air pour que les choses
bougent parce que personne n'en a rien à
[ __ ] est-ce que tu peux nous rappeler
ce qui se passe alors en fait c'est une
histoire qui est très représentative de
ce qu'on vit de nos jours c'est une
histoire en fait de quelqu'un que je ne
connaissais ni d'avenir d'Adam un
blogueur du nom d'Aquaba qui s'est mis à
balancer tout et n'importe quoi sur moi
pour pour exister et vas-y que j'étais
complice de viol et que j'étais
pédophilie et compagnie donc après bah
ça s'emballe ça va très vite sur les
réseaux
un gamin était manipulé par un paparazzi
pour déposer plein de contre moi alors
que vous ne l'avez jamais vu il a
ensuite retiré sa plainte en avant avoir
menti est-ce que vous regrettez
finalement d'être vous-même un produit
des réseaux sociaux Jeremstar alors ce
que je regrette c'est mon passé ça c'est
certain parce que j'ai moi-même
contribué à un système où je pouvais
participer à des vagues de harcèlement
envers certains candidats télé-réalité
j'y allais pas avec le dos de la
cuillère et j'ai été vraiment un vrai
connard par le passé je présente
vraiment très sincèrement mes excuses
aux gens que j'ai blessé à mes débuts et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui voilà d'avoir eu
cette ce pense pendant là de pour me
faire connaître me permet d'être
crédible je pense dans ma lutte contre
le cyberharcèlement parce que j'ai été
des deux côtés j'entends souvent si
c'est si dur ici on est si fragile alors
on s'expose pas sur les réseaux c'est le
prix à payer la justice m'a dit ça mais
oui mais il suffit d'éteindre son
téléphone mais enfin on dit pas un gamin
car cela à l'école arrête d'être
scolarisé ou dans un autre registre on
dit pas une jeune femme qui est violée
arrête de porter le mini jupe ça n'est
pas à moi de quitter les réseaux sociaux
c'est aux gens qui s'y comportent mal
d'en être interdit vous savez combien ça
m'a coûté 5 ans après parce qu'il y a
encore des des c'est dur judiciaire en
cours
200000 euros ce que j'ai une dizaine de
procédures en fait entre les magazines
entre les les faux plaignants les
harceleurs les journalistes les ce
journaliste par exemple qui était
condamné en première instance à de la
prison il y va pas parce que en France
quand on est condamné à moins de 2 ans
de prison on y va pas donc en fait j'ai
quoi j'ai un document qui m'a coûté
200000 balles juste pour mon ego
m'indiquant que oui on l'a reconnu
coupable mais moi j'ai perdu mes
spectacles j'ai perdu mon poste sur C8
par exemple à l'époque j'étais en parler
j'ai jamais été poursuivi donc du coup
jamais blanchi enfin et du jour au
lendemain voilà je suis devenu une merde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]